enfant en tête du box office une
coproduction pro 6 10 fr3 et radio
canada
il était une fois l'espace suite d'une
série à succès programmé par notre
chaîne et qui s'intitulait il était une
fois l'homme bien nous sommes ravis
parce que notre nouvelle production
était fort bien reçu
il est vrai que l'émission précédente a
eu un succès absolument internationale
qu'elle a été vendue dans plus de 60
pays
ce qui je crois pour une série française
est extrêmement exceptionnelle et que
sur le crédit de cette dernière série
je pense que les gens nous font
confiance et désire nous suivre puisque
nous reprenons les mêmes personnages
dans d'autres aventures